hello everyone and welcome to
rec league the esports show that dares
to play the games
no one else will i'm the guy with a tie
forest shaw here with my co-host orlando
leyba
that's right forest i'm orlando and
tonight
we will be playing the most fantastic
game in the world
bus simulator 18.
tonight we will watch as two fierce
competitors put it all on the line
as they fight to the death to see who's
better at driving a fake digital bus
slowly and carefully around a made-up
town
i can't wait fame glory and the coveted
rec leaf trophy await tonight's winner
but first as is reckless league
tradition orlando and i will
engage in a little commentator small
talk
so how's it going orlando oh it's going
better than yesterday and surely worse
than tomorrow
how about you forest not bad i ate a
whole bag of doritos last night
big sweatpants under this table but
pretty good other than that was there
any crying involved
no no it's the dorito dust sticks to
your fingers if you cry
you know okay enough of that
now it's time to meet our players
i'm grayson golden glue gilmer i'm a
professional league of legends player
and i'm excited to start my bus
simulator 18 career
right now tonight on reckles golden glue
how are you doing
i'm doing well i'm excited to compete
it's a it's a big day
uh golden doodle question for me uh have
you ever rode on a bus
i have rode on a bus i've rode on school
buses i rode on public transport buses
uh it's very instilled in me so i'm
excited to uh
you know just relay all those
experiences that i i've had into this
game
are you anti-headboard do you stand with
headboards or anti-headboards
i'm at uh currently staying with my
family about my mom's place i've got a
place
uh in la my apartment i do have a
headboard here but this is kind of more
like
og uh gamer 18 year old
you know no headboard and got time for
that ain't got money for that but at my
apartment in l.a i do
give us your thoughts on your opponent i
looked at his youtube channel
alfred's got some cool videos out he
plays some good games he's playing some
super smash bros so he has good taste in
games
he plays casual games so this shouldn't
really be a problem beating him he's a
casual gamer he plays for fun and i'm a
competitor so
i don't really think it's gonna be much
of a challenge today i'm excited to
play stop a casual player and
golden glue's competitor for tonight is
alpharet
hi i'm alfred and tonight i will be
leaving my legacy behind
as the greatest bus simulator 18 player
ever on rec league
say hello to alpharad how you doing
alfred doing well how are you
i'm okay thanks for asking i don't know
if you heard the doritos thing earlier
but
um we're recovering from that it's just
a formality
uh well thanks for being here uh tell us
a little bit about yourself alfred
i don't know what there is to say
honestly i have
been studying buses i have i i think
that's i think that speaks for itself i
hopefully hopefully
my gameplay will say everything that
you're asking what would be your
favorite bus since you've been doing
researches on buses
i'm gonna say yellow ones yellow ones
alpha rad give us your thoughts on your
opponent
it's very pretty boy has a nice circular
frame
glasses and he just hits me with that
woke up early for sunday school haircut
and how can you not love that how do you
feel like you're gonna do tonight
i i am going to
go home in a blaze of glory or fail
miserably i only play in absolutes
you're already home though so yeah
you're kind of she's going to stay in
the same place pretty much right
yeah okay it's time to fire up the game
golden glue and alpha red let's create
your bus companies
[Applause]
i'm naming mine golden glue's gambit
like it was my own it's my own ship it's
my own boat
i'm just naming my company's winter pov
for convenience sake
all right create all right here we go i
don't know what to expect
i'm just going for this all gold giant
right here these hair colors are really
weird they don't have a very good blonde
color yeah i kind of like his his energy
right now
we have to have a golden tie golden
pants
that's what i was looking for i think we
actually made the exact same character
i hope not
here are the rules for tonight's
competition the competition will be the
best of three so the first player to win
two rounds
is our rec league champion the first
round will consist of just straight
driving how well can you
follow the rules drive your route get
your passengers where they need to be in
a timely and safe manner this round will
be judged on whomever has the most stars
at the end of the round
well golden glue and alpha red those are
the rules
so let's give you this countdown three
two one bus
all right i've got the garage door open
i'll figure out any time that will be
off
um okay i'm actually concerned because
uh
i am a drive but the the games seems to
disagree with me oh you probably have a
back door open that's what mine is i had
a bathroom
and we're off i got to
oh oh true true true yeah now we're off
maybe okay well
uh come on in passengers perfect
stopping position it assists
okay well i am uh i am still stuck in
and
what they claim is drive man there's an
old lady just sitting right outside the
bus but she's not getting in
all right all right i don't know what i
did but we're we're going and the
traffic's insane right now
i can't believe i'm waiting in traffic
in a game that's the craziest part
it's too realistic oh good stopping
position as always
let me in please my bus is full of
grandmas i only have grandmas on my bus
no way this is the it's not even a light
this truck's just not moving thank you
all right we're taking off road i'm not
waiting
my passengers have places to be yeah you
know if there wasn't a competition i
would storm through all
i'll what who's to say i can't squeeze
through this crowd of people
yeah see no one got hurt everything's
fine let's see if our grandma's gonna
get off the bus
all right back on the road are you
supposed to use our mirrors honest
question
i think my favorite part is printing
tickets i don't know why but there's
something really satisfying about no i
agree
i think tickets and doing simple
arithmetic the basic math is very
satisfying
especially complimented with my perfect
timing and perfect stopping position
all right no one's getting on or off
here all right makes my job easy
just pedal to the metal a moderate metal
i should say i'm on my last stop right
here
and i got out of the garage like a whole
minute after so i think i'm doing
excellent i'm just a late bloomer
nothing wrong with that
okay here we are i think i got a little
desperate to catch up with you and
made some reckless decisions here and
there the next round
i will leave the garage in appropriate
time
that's round one let's look at the score
golden glue
you got three and a half stars and alpha
rad
two and a half two and three quarters
there so it looks like gold and glue is
our winner
w for the boys
just shy of three stars apparently i had
three collisions
three and a half stars that's it i sw i
did not have three collisions
oh i had five though
the buses are all gassed up and our
players are ready to go we'll be back a
little bit later for our rec league
competition
see you soon
welcome back to rec league the only
esports show that dares to make the most
ridiculous games competitive
i'm flora shaw and as always i'm here
with my co-host orlando leyva
that's right forest tonight we get to
play
bus simulator 18. let's check back in
with our players golden glue where do
you feel like you had the edge
um i i had the edge in the fact that i
started earlier and i i just ran into
less people my driving skills are just a
bit better
um you know it it was it was a decent
run it wasn't it won't be
as good as my next two runs but it was
it was a good start alpha i saw that you
left the garage a little bit later
but then you managed to catch up at the
end
what was your strategy how did you get
there bud reckless
driving and you can see how it was a
blessing and a curse
all at the same time because i think
i was checked out a little bit after a
while i just assumed that run was dead
on arrival
but if you look at those collisions i
had two collisions on the way back to
the garage and i think that would have
been the difference
which i do think this is very generous
for a bus driver
because if i hear that a bus driver in
real life had five collisions
and a five minute run they're two and a
half stars on yelp
alfred what are some adjustments you
think you're going to make going into
the next round
um if i had to think of something
perhaps hit fewer cars alright we're
ready for our second round
let's look at the rules for round two
the second round will be a speed round
who can drive the route the fastest and
get back to the garage
turn off their bus and exit the vehicle
first you'll need to stop at each stop
and at least open your doors for the
stop to count
golden glue alpha red your time begins
three two one
bus
it's a national holiday today more
people will take the bus than usual
what not a national holiday for me see
if i can get this car started little
rocky
movement in there but uh it'll come
alive all right we're in drive it should
go
uh not going yet i don't know why
oh parking brake was on and we're out i
i don't know why it's a holiday
oh my god there's so many people at my
bus stop
i think you underestimate how lucky i am
that has historically been my thing
oh my god i ran into the lamppost i'm
closing my door on all of them i don't
need them it's all about time
oh my god oh i'm in reverse such a nice
day oh no no don't come in don't come in
don't come in
all right i'm tense now
i just okay like straight up that
doesn't make any sense game's fault i
understand
i think my car might be broken oh
yeah he needs to see it oh no i'm just
uh casually gaming over here don't mind
me
dude this bus sucks let me print out my
first ticket of the day
there's literally a hundred people at
all my bus stops by the way
shouldn't have driven on christmas
that's all i'm saying look i've honestly
done an incredible job i haven't even
hit a car this run it's been insane
i mean i might just do it just for fun
you know just feel something
all right there we go sorry it just
didn't feel right otherwise saturday i
do love how this bus is so good
at pushing all other cars out of the way
what stop are you at
stop it's cute that's really cute
wow wow wow that's it after two rounds
we have a tie
tie alpha rad you're the winner of the
second round
what went right i think it just really
came down to
the better player one you know that's
just how i see it
before the final match as is rec league
tradition
each player will give their bus an
inspiring speech
all right gold and glue's gambit
this is our ride this is our drive
it's all about speed it's all about no
stops and this is where we change our
whole lives
with the rec league trophy all we gotta
do is win one more round
and our lives could be better forever
let's do this where do i start
no one seats 28 people like you do no
one has an 8.6
meter turn radius like you do and you're
my ride or die
and i mean that you're the ride that
causes die and i couldn't ask for
anything more and we will
take that to the grave literally and
figuratively i mean what can't you do
you know we will make this happen
together as we
destroy every other car in our path to
find victory
because this is the winner pov all right
i got goosebumps on that one i felt that
i felt that
let's look at the rules for our final
round
the final round will be the penalty
round each player will have five minutes
to rack up as
many penalties as they can in the time
allotted the player who has lost the
most money that round will be the winner
all right alpharad uh how do you feel
going in this last round what's your
strategy
to play the exact same way i have been
the entire time
golden glue any final adjustments um you
know
i think if i can just get my car up and
running and i can hit as many things as
possible
i think we're gonna pull through okay
it's the final round
three two one bus
i'm showing the pedestrian some love i'm
thinking i'm trying to take out every
pedestrian
i'm i'm focusing cars i'm hitting
everything really
i'm uh you know just walking on the curb
for extra extra penalties here and there
i feel like the ultimate predator right
now yeah i am unhinged
like you definitely understand morality
a whole bunch more
whenever you see this bus in its actual
size
do i have to replace the bus is that a
penalty if i drive into a lake of water
i gotta make some tight turn for
something that might not pay off
she's poor pedestrians no no uh
uh guys yeah yeah i think i'm at a very
disadvantageous position to say say the
least it's a holiday too
these poor pedestrians they're just
trying to have a good holiday and then
golden glue's gambit comes through
okay that's the end of round three let's
look at the results here
uh golden glue you owe a lot of money
yeah it's a lot of money you killed a
lot of people and
looks like you are the winner at
negative eight hundred
and seventeen thousand and yeah change
euros
well i just wanna be straight we don't
know if we killed anybody we just hate
the pedestrians it could be light
injuries
i know with the bus they could be set
for life on their insurance like maybe
they have to pay off their college loans
like honestly
i could have been doing them a favor so
let's just i just want to put that out
there
golden glue i gotta tell you man it was
it was a beautiful thing
watching you throw your morals out the
window golden glue can i ask at the top
how many collisions did you have
fourteen collisions fourteen collections
yeah so i was just in the wrong business
see you already you you are in the wrong
business i've been the best in the wrong
stock and you are in the business of
losing i am alpha if you had it uh to do
all over again would you hit more people
definitely would have been a national
holiday on my screen
golden glue you are the champion and
here is your rec league trophy
yeah baby
alpharad nobody leaves empty-handed here
on rec league
congratulations you won the trophy of
shane
wait wait what a sec wait a second
is it possible for people to leave
empty-handed then
well we're gonna mail it to you we are
we already bought it
that's gonna do it for this installment
of rec league thank you to our players
golden glue and alpharad and of course
thank you to my co-host orlando leyva
and i'll just like to thank all the bus
drivers out there wherever you are in
the world
and to all the bus simulators you are
the real heroes
all right that's it thank you for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Applause]